people have been serving sauerbraten in
the Rhineland for more than 150 years
but some foreign visitors don't seem to
know much about it Viney such Oprah - so
Bob wha is domme I don't know real River
something twice I don't know I maybe
some places I could join me or something
like that
Sawa bråten is a hearty main dish it's
on the menu at many Cologne restaurants
including vintage right on the banks of
the Rhine head chef news opening shows
us how it's made start by marinating the
meat for three to five days before you
need it
use carrots onions and celery to make
the marinade add juniper berries mustard
seeds and bay leaves and then there's
the essential part vinegar and red wine
the acid in the vinegar breaks down the
fibers in the meat preserving and
tenderizing it the meat can remain in
the marinade for up to a week
way back when they didn't use the best
cuts that's why you marinated it softens
the meat in the rhineland any times the
right time for sauerbraten most every
family has its own recipe betel
Heintzman has been researching the
region's culinary culture for 30 years
little has been written about
sauerbraten besides the story of its
origins there were a number of different
ways to preserve meat back then they
dried it or salted it or pickled it in
vinegar no fridges back then after all
so is our button probably developed from
the need to make something keep for a
while many say the traditional meat used
to make a Heinlein sauerbraten came from
horses but that's wrong until the end of
the 19th century consumption of horse
meat was even banned by the church that
doesn't rule out poor people going to
the knackers yard and buying horse meat
on the sly but we don't have any
evidence that horse meat was primarily
used for his our bond on the contrary
people actually made it out of pork on
special occasions for the simple reason
that pork was considered a top quality
meat especially in the 19th century to
see how holy bechet's and garden loins
in yonder
but the special thing about Sawa Pradhan
from this region is the gravy
Raisins go into it giving it a touch of
sweetness
Brian lenders love the combination of
hearty sweet and sour
besides sauerbraten many other dishes
from here combine the same qualities
in the rhineland sauerbraten is
traditionally served with potato
dumplings homemade red cabbage and apple
sauce but there is also sauerbraten from
other parts of germany the ingredients
vary from region to region in northern
Bavaria sauerbraten is served with bread
crumbs and apple slices in the southwest
Swabians have it with spaetzle and
potato salad in Saxony they make the
gravy richer with a bit of cream and as
we've already said raisins of the key in
there I meant it has an unusual taste I
can only say that it tastes like design
Lanza Baba you've got to know the
flavour like tasty but if there's one
thing essential with Rhineland
sauerbraten its Kerch the regional beer
served in small glasses